and welcome to Hannity We Begin tonight
with a Fox News Alert it is 900 p.m. on
the East Coast 6:00 p.m. on the west
coast it is 4 a.m. in Gaza where the
lights tonight again are out power has
been severed from the city as Israel now
continues to besiege Hamas in
preparation for what will be a fullscale
ground assault that could begin frankly
at any moment as prime minister Benjamin
nanyu said this Invasion will resonate
with Israel's enemy for generations and
will change the Middle East now more
than 100,000 Israeli soldiers they are
now amassing at gaza's border over
300,000 reservists have been called up
in only the last 48 hours residents of
Gaza reportedly received this text
message telling them to flee to Egypt
immediately quote you stay you die now I
can tell you and I can promise you been
a longtime friend of Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and I can
assure you that he means everything that
he says and he will follow through
unlike your President Joe Biden who is
weak and frail in a cognitive mess
Israel happens to have a very strong
leader now the days of Hamas brutalizing
the region they are now officially
numbered this will now end hopefully
once and for all and the only people to
blame for all of this well that would be
Hamas the terror group that has in their
Charter the destruction of Israel and
Iran that we now was was involved in the
plotting and the planning and the
scheming in the Iranian revolutionary
guard and they gave their approval
anyway this group Hamas is about to be
fully eliminated from the planet Earth
Israel cannot and must not accept
anything less than that you cannot
coexist with evil with monsters and the
more that we learn about last weekend's
barbaric Terror attacks well the worst
it gets here's a viewer warning I would
actually really like to show all of this
to you what we're about to show you is
extremely gruesome but every adult
frankly every adult American you need to
see this you need to fully absorb what
is the reality of evil in this world in
our time or frankly you'll never
understand the need to defeat it and
destroy it what is evil about it's all
about killing stealing and destroying
and over the weekend it was on display
an army of Hamas terrorists they went
door Todo breaking into homes murdering
entire families in the most brutal ways
imaginable before killing the family pet
and setting homes a blaze well some
Israelis were shot others were stabbed
women were beaten women were raped
elderly even Holocaust Survivors and
young kids were abducted according to
one report one young Israeli couple they
were murdered inside of their home but
they were able to save their twin babies
by hiding them in a safe room as their
parents lay dead in a pool of blood well
those two babies left alone for 12 hours
before they were rescued other infants
they were not so lucky hamash shot one
pregnant woman in the stomach she did
survive her unborn child did not take a
look at your screen well right there
these are the bodies dead bodies from
one small town in southern Israel where
we now now know and have confirmed at
least 40 babies were murdered babies and
some beheaded by Hamas how sick can and
low can people go take a look I'm
talking to some of the soldiers and they
say what they've witnessed as they've
been walking through these different
houses these different communities uh
babies their heads cut off that's what
they said gunned down families
completely gunned down in their
beds you can see some of these soldiers
right now comforting each other many of
them reserves uh who jumped into action
leaving their own families behind as
well not knowing the sheer horror that
they were about to come
to I really want all of you to see this
evil we can't show you the worst video
frankly it would be too gruesome for TV
I I had my way editorial control I'd
probably show it but you know what I
understand these are images that will
stick with you for the rest of your life
remember Isis beheadings yeah because of
my job I had to watch it those images
will never be erased for my brain
elderly women they're executed while
their murders are live streamed on
social media uh living rooms covered in
nothing but blood men women children
dead on the floor as Hamas terrorists
come back over and over and over again
filling their lifeless bodies with yet
more bullets and more bullets more than
a thousand innocent civilians including
at least 14 of our fellow Americans
murdered mured in a single day if you
want to look at it and and compare it to
our population and Israel's population
it would be the equivalent of over
35,000 Americans killed in a single day
wow many others abducted and now being
held hostage inside Gaza not a lot of
Hope for them tonight I pray I'm wrong
this also includes Americans held
hostage and now Hamas is vowing to
execute them one by one live on the
internet and there are already multiple
videos of hostages being executed by
Hamas one American who's abducted by
Hamas during the music festival sent
this final text to his mother quote I
love you I'm sorry according to
Witnesses on the ground he lost an arm
from the elbow down during the attack
loaded on the back of a pickup truck
with five other hostages they were
driven away what kind of people you know
act like this how does a person do
something that
unspeakable how did these terrorists
become so evil have you ever thought
about that I don't think people are born
evil with this kind of Venom and this
kind of hate uh we do know this kind of
vile Behavior can be learned how do we
know the children in Gaza they have been
brainwashed they have been indoctrinated
they have been taught to hate Jews and
Christians from the earliest ages and
hate Americans from the earliest ages
for example let's take a look at this
cartoon it was obtained by memory TV
which was produced for young children in
the Gaza Strip look at this this is
indoctrination this is a brain this is
brainwashing of children
[Music]
watch
and as they get older they get taught
that if they martyr themselves well 72
virgins await them in heaven
now it gets worse there are actual
terror training camps for children
actually inside of Gaza with simulated
attacks against quote the Jews this is
how your tax money by the way is being
spent money that Joe Biden has given
them terror training camps for children
anti-semitic cartoons grenades Rockets
ammunitions Tunnels for terrorists they
supposed to be using that cement
electricity oh for hospitals and schools
no they build tunnels so they can you
know sneak into Israel capture and kill
Israelis plenty of of weaponry and more
bad news by the way this radical extrem
extremism has been exported all around
the globe take a look at your screen
this was the free Palestine crowd in New
York City take a look there celebrate I
think that's the one where the guy has a
Nazi Insignia um you know celebrating
this weekend's Terror attacks smiling
chanting yep building up a picture of a
swas sticker similar celebrations taking
place in London in England and in Sydney
in Australia where free Palestine
demonstrators there were chanting quote
gas the Jews don't believe me take a
look gas the Jews and Jewish people in
Australia have been told to stay home
wow back in Chicago the group black
lives matter they're standing in
solidarity with Hamas posting this image
apparently glorifying the terrorist
paragliders the ones that raped murdered
abducted hundreds of young unarmed
civilians at that concert dedicated to
peace that's where 260 innocent people
uh plus were killed meanwhile student
leaders on college campuses around this
country are planning a day of resistance
to support the terrorist group Hamas
dozens of student groups at havid 31
groups directly blaming Israel alone for
what happened all coming together in
support of Hamas is this what they're
learning at Harvard University bigotry
anti-Semitism outright hate really in in
in in this politically correct world
this woke world this cancel culture
world that's okay with Harvard and these
and these you know alumni and all of
these people that donate you know
billions of dollars really it's truly
vile people now walk among us that have
been indoctrinated by communist
professors that clearly sympathize with
terrorism and terrorists others have
been infiltrating or wide openen
Southern border by the way for years
look at this according to a leaked
internal report from US Customs and
Border Protection we have thousands of
special interest aliens from Middle
Eastern countries they've all crossed
our border since 20121 thanks Joe do we
know who they are do do we know why
they're here who financed their Journey
do we know how many Got Away undetected
across our wide open borders uh is
anyone in the Biden administration at
all concerned about this at the end of
this Joe Biden's thirdd year as
president he will have allowed aided and
and eded over 8 million illegal
immigrants into this country with zero
vetting I can guarantee you Terror cells
uh are in this country as part of that 8
million figure and that means they are
plotting and planning and scheming
another 911 or worse and you can thank
Joe Biden and his open borders policy
when that happens mark my words now I
pray that I'm wrong but I doubt it we'll
wake up one day today oh it turns out
they came in when Joe left the borders
wide open and 99% of those people were
allowed to stay what about the Americans
who are now being held hostage Joe what
is the White House doing to rescue them
because you pretty much told Americans
that can't get out of Israel because
commercial airlines are not flying into
it yeah you're pretty much on your own
what are you going to do this time
another Afghanistan great families are
now begging Biden to do more we paid for
almost a thousand aircraft jet aircraft
that this country owns maybe you can
send Air Force One over to pick them up
as of this afternoon one family had yet
to receive any communication from the
Biden White House not even a phone call
and by the way during Biden's short
speech today he didn't even mention Iran
the country you know behind last
weekend's attack the number one state
sponsor of Terror there were no strong
words no com uh condemnation of the
mullers in Iran nothing indicating a
plan to hold Iran responsible as they
should be held of course no word if
Biden will refreeze the $6 billion he
recently made available to the mullers
when he paid a ransom for five American
hostages no Joe Biden your president is
too busy kissing the asses of the number
one state sponsor of Terror worldwide
that's right the Iranian mullus and get
this according to one of Biden's top
officials John Kirby talking to our own
Martha mallum despite everything that is
now unfolding in the Middle East and
Russia and China he believes yeah
climate change is an existential threat
the top National Security concern even
more important if you can believe it or
not than even nuclear war I don't make
this up take a look given that the
United States is now involved in wars
that are taking place in Europe and also
in the Middle East I I I want to play
this sound bite for you that is just
last month in Vietnam and ask you if
this still holds for the president
watch the only existential threat
Humanity faces even more frightening
than a than a nuclear war is global
warming going above 1.5 degrees in the
next 20 10 years given all the nuclear
players in these two areas where we are
now engaged on does the president stand
by that comment absolutely he does
climate change is an existential threat
it could you know it actually threatens
and is capable of wiping out all human
life on Earth uh over time I mean that's
I don't know how more existentially you
can get to
that I I I just can't believe what I'm
hearing Joe Biden on top of being a
complete cognitive mess is frankly a
complete ignorant fool to hold that
belief the world is burning the Biden
White House is Sid track with of course
their far-left fantasy their adherence
to the the climate alarmist religious
cult which they bow at the altar of
while the leader of the Free World
cowers Behind Closed Doors but while
Biden is showing weakness well Israel
will go It Alone preparing for what will
be a historic show of Force pay
attention Joe you might learn something
this could reshape and likely will
reshape the region forever and a message
will be sent loudly and clearly to every
terrorist in the world don't mess with
Israel cuz you're going to get your
asses kicked Mark words that's coming
next hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else